you are making snoop dogg proud tonight
you know that you know it was crazy as
snoop dogg is in the movie i know he
plays the joint he plays the joint i
mean dude
this is snoop came to the premiere dude
this is crazy hold up i thought he was
booked too but here no no here he is
this is insane bro we love you snoop
thanks for being in the movie yeah you
already know nephew it's all good bro
that's all i love man i'm happy to be a
part of a stoner classic thank you so
much i love you um yo you are a vibe and
speaking of i mean you got to
collaborate with your bestie matsun plus
you got all the homies in this like talk
to me about the vibe on set
we uh we made a promise to ourselves
like
if we aren't making people laugh on set
off camera
then we we gotta just pack up and go
home and so like
the first day when people couldn't even
hold the camera straight because the
laughs were happening we knew we were
making we knew we were making the right
choice
uh your boy pete davidson was also in
this movie i mean is it a trip i mean in
2018 y'all were living together in his
mom's apartment and look at you two
thriving how does that feel it's like an
example of
not to sound cliche but but you know not
giving up
it is a trip because there's so many
times when you're ready to clock out and
you know this movie actually you know
it's funny it came from
kind of like a depressed place and then
turned into a comedy so it's it's it's
funny how when you start to like invite
light into your life uh it it it'll
it'll find its way to
to manifest in that way so
speaking of that light you got to share
the screen of course with your beautiful
fiance megan uh again actually but what
was it like to direct her this time
around i just think she's comedically
genius like i think she's
so underrated as a
comic actor and angelus is an actor who
can adapt to different faces and uh
phases
so
um it was an honor and she
it's
it's so funny i like i was trying to
like
make her not look like megan fox
pink hair well in other way i was like
we should put like an old lady wiggling
on you and
all these and then she was like i got
this and she just showed up on set and
she was her and she was kennedy and i
was like
and kennedy is also kind of like an odds
uh to reagan from new girl you know so
it's like it's like a good like uh
everything was kind of meta going
throwback yeah yeah yeah uh listen how
is the wedding planning going i mean
what's it like to collaborate with megan
on this big day
on the on the wedding yeah oh we called
it off you did no
i was like breaking news right now and
she's coming to the premiere still yeah
yeah how is that all coming together i
know obviously you've been looking for
the right location for the right gothic
vibe how's it going
i'm going to leave that kind of like a a
present for the world to unwrap when it
happens so i'll just yeah would you
consider your wedding to be the greatest
project you ever worked on because i
feel like your wheels are turning you
got a lot of grand ideas for what is
going to be a really special day for you
love is probably the biggest project
i've ever worked on yeah so yeah
everything encompassing that i put you
know i
i give
that more energy than i give my work so
like it's harder to
work on a relationship or is it harder
to direct a film
it's easy for me to yell at corporate
companies
that are funding the movie so it's not
easy to yell at my partner so like
[Music]
you